well just as the raiders season comes to
an end the golden knights drop the puck
on the 2021 season
in just a few weeks and camp started
today kevin martin was at city national
arena getting our first look at the team
favored to hoist the stanley cup this
summer we all came here to work
the golden knights open training camp
today for the 2021
nhl season and with just 10 days before
their first game
every single practice is crucial it's
definitely a quick turnaround and
by me thought today was a really good
day with no exhibition games and a
shortened season
the golden knights know they must come
out of the gates hot
you know you can't get behind eight ball
early you gotta jump on the front and
take full boundary first game so i think
that's kind of the
um what coaching staff and everybody's
preaching here
uh just uh you know right out of the
gate
be one of the top teams and everybody
believes that we can be
alex petrangelo took the ice for the
first time in a golden knights jersey
and the newly signed defenseman is
excited to get going with his new squad
i mean first day is always a bit you
know a bit of a scatter where
the energy's probably at its highest
everyone's excited to kind of get things
going but
you know as we get on through camp and
start playing uh
some more script managers i think uh
continuing to get more fun because you
can just see the energy for us right
it's
fun to get back and play some real
hockey petrangelo and the rest of the
golden knights host anaheim on january
14th to kick off the season and while
there will be countless changes this
year
possibly the biggest will be playing at
t-mobile with no
fans t-mobile is the loudest rank in the
the nhl is the great
the greatest place to play in and i
think i can find another word then just
it's sad to to see timo that we're going
to see t-mobile like that
kevin martin ate sports now